um let's roll the cameras
oh my lands over a thousand let's go
and we're playing clover star one i'm
gonna play e4
amy cloverstar and let's hope we get a
danish gambit
we still have not been able to get a
danish and nobody seems to take the pawn
and if they do they don't take the other
pawn
yep they start thinking and then they'll
play like knight c6 or d6
we've had knight f6 here uh what haven't
we had here
and there's knight c6
[Music]
so those of you who have been very
attentive
know that there are several options here
there's knight to f3 which transposes
into the scotch
that's fine there's d5 and i'll talk
about that after the game
i keep forgetting to do that d5 is not
as good as it looks
what should we do here what should we do
here
well i haven't given you guys much of a
choice i'm saying it's not knight f3
it's not d5
you actually take right and
i've explained this previously where it
looks bad like why are we letting black
establish knight in the center well
that knight has no support right and we
could later play f4 we could play knight
f3
just tonight in the center this early in
the game is
not particularly meaningful it can
actually be counterproductive so we
don't want to play a four
yet what do we play here again we've had
this position once before
we want to develop very flexibly let's
see how black puts his pieces
before we decide whether we play f4 what
that means is we need to play
an inoffensive development move that we
will play regardless and we know we're
going to play this movie anyway yeah
right under no circumstances are you not
going to play knight c3
if black plays not f6 that's what we've
previously faced that is a big mistake
and i'll ask you guys if he plays it
which is quite likely
to remind me
they ain't calling me the prophet for
nothing to remind me of what i should do
here
and the underpinning here right is i
think
i found a good analogy here but i don't
remember
what that analogy was but black is
developing his pieces but he's not
laying out the exoskeleton right pawns
provide the skeleton
that that create meaning for positioning
of the pieces
right now the knights are sort of in no
man's land
and we can just push them all away with
our pawns just bowl them over right just
send the bowling ball down the lane f4
that's a committal move but it's
associated with the follow-up we
wouldn't play this move we're not for
the follow-up which is e5
and the knight on f6 has to go back to
ga that is
not a total disaster but it's really bad
and
he's going to be intro now this knight
has to go back here here
knight g4 would be further exacerbate
the situation
okay so knight c6 we're gonna go e5 the
knight has only one legal square
well it's more than one legal square but
only one reasonable square in ig8
now we have a big center and we have a
development advantage we also have a
slightly weakened king which means that
we can't take the foot off the gas pedal
we have to keep developing very actively
but we don't have to reinvent the wheel
here so what do we do
thank you minko for the prime
what do we do yeah just knight f3 and no
need for anything
crazy now i think this position occurred
in our previous game
d6 is what black should do he does you
see
these players have begun to play a
little bit better
and now i explained
in the previous game that
when you've got these positions people
often assume that queen trades are
inherently bad
and that's not quite the case sometimes
a queen trade is
actually okay because the remaining
pieces can still provide you
a very big initiative that means we
don't have to move our queen out of d1
we we are okay with the queen trade
potentially
but let's set that queen straight up how
can we ensure
that in the event of d takes e5 the
queen trait forces black to lose
castling rights
sorry that was a pretty convoluted
question but i think some of you
understood
and the move is so bishop c4 is tempting
but the classy move is bishop to b5
preparing for d takes e5
then we take the queen because the
knight is spin he's got to take with the
king
because we're so ahead in development we
still would have had a strong attack he
goes bishop d7 instead that's a little
passive
now we don't have to do anything we can
just castle
and look at this f file that f file is
where the disaster is going to happen
he's helping us by taking
what should we take back with the knight
or the pawn
we should of course stick with fun
there's no need to take with a knife why
would you know why trade
p unnecessary pieces and help him out
yeah so we just stick with the pawn
and looks like let me just write this
down
okay so he's in huge trouble look at the
spawn it's containing the knight
this f-file is disastrous for black this
knight can coax g5 and he goes queen
to e7 now
my sort of pattern recognizer
immediately supplies the move because i
associate queen e7 in the opening
when you've got a knight on c3 and he
plays queen e7 there's immediately in
the snap of a finger move you should be
looking for knight t5
but because we have moved our pawn away
from f2
you have to also put a red flag there
right that creates certain tactical
possibilities along this diagonal so we
have to consider
knight d5 queen c5 check and at first
blush you might be like oh no we lose a
piece
because that is a fork against the
bishop but
let's not stop there if you look at that
position carefully you'll notice
that that is a phantom threat can
somebody explain to me what i'm talking
about here
yeah because knight takes c7 is going to
be a fork and not only is that going to
fork the rook that's going to fork a
queen which may land on b5 in fact that
very likely
he will play queen c5 check because one
of the common mistakes at this level
is players are much better at detecting
tactical patterns
but not as good at calculating them
deeply
and not as good at figuring out when to
stop calculating so
they will get attracted by the bishop
and i have this sort of executive
control to say okay
i see that i can win the bishop but let
me make sure
that you know if i calculate one move
further than that
that i'm not missing some sort of a
detail and the game is over his queen is
literally trapped he has no other spot
he essentially either has to give up the
queen
where it is for a piece or he's got to
take the bishop and the game is over
so this isn't rocket science per se it's
it's a
mentality thing right you have to force
yourself
uh in situations with extenuating
circumstances like here you know light
is up in development
so there's very it's very likely that
there's going to be a lot of tactics in
the air
so that's why you have to keep
calculating and you have to be
opportunistic here
and um yeah
thank you all pdx yeah i mean it's it's
pretty straightforward
also like this is relatively common
yeah so well knight d4 yeah maybe he
should play that but then we can
yeah probably knight d4 is the best move
but then we take his bishop and we can
even take his night with our queen you
know
yep he's realizing it
he's realizing it
and i remember an early game the only
time that i ever smothered mated someone
in my
over-the-board chess career i think
featured something very similar let me
look up that game i for some reason i
remember
that i won the queen in this fashion but
it was a very long time ago so
i might be forgetting let me check
i feel like it was a similar scenario
um
oh well it was similar but it wasn't
worth showing
it's okay so he finds it
yeah knight d4 is the best move
relatively speaking
but it's not going to help him now there
are several options here
we can play queen takes d4 being up a
piece in the end game
no problem with that let's find the
surgical move the surgical move is
simply to realize that
now the knight is pinned by the bishop
there's a
problem here which is that he can unpin
himself with check
by taking the knight but if you look
very carefully at the situation
of this king and the fact that the queen
is x-raying the king i always advocate
look for those x-rays any time your
queen your opponent's king is in the
same file no matter how many pieces are
between them
that should be factored in and we have a
very simple move here
that preserves the queens and still wins
the piece what am i talking about it
what am i talking about rather yeah
knight c3
yeah i love the i love these kinds of
moves we just dropped the knight back
and now we use this pin to immobilize
the night we're going to pick up the
pick up the knight the king is going to
be toast and we're going to be a piece
kudos to my opponent for finding this
but he's still completely lost
right sorry i hope the logic makes sense
here
yeah yeah it's just over
over red rover rook d i mean it's a good
move
so we can take with a knight um we can
take with the bishop we can take with
the queen and it doesn't really matter
i think the best thing is to take with a
knight because
i some of you guys oh no no actually
we have something kind of sexy here
let's stick with the bishop
take that's what i assume most of you
people
are instinctively thinking about because
that sets up a discovery check the thing
the
tricky thing with discover checks is
that
they can be very appealing but sometimes
you don't have a good one right
and that may be the case here unless you
sort of really put your imagination
i'm sort of your your turn up the
creativity dial
what do i notice here what do i see i
see this this immediately
signals to my brain ah fork where can
this fork be delivered e5 what's on e5 a
pawn
we also have a discovered check so let's
go e6 right
and the rest i don't even calculate he
can certainly take the queen
but the second thing that this move
accomplishes
is it opens up another sort of diagonal
for the bishop which
uh which allows and i'll show this after
the game second discovered check
that is over that is another super
thematic tactical idea
clearing out a square and that's the
queen and that's the game
now if we want to play very precisely i
noticed that g7
is sort of a takeable pawn in some
circumstances so
this is not mandatory but what should we
do
like what can we do here in the in the
name of playing aggressively
yeah well queen g4 is a great move but
what i'm talking about here is rook
takes f8 and we should be seven
yeah i know black black is playing fine
i mean he's playing playing very well
for his rating
but it's not going to be enough here
it's not going to be enough
okay yeah bishop g7
and we're going to pick up a rook he'll
probably go 97 i mean that's the only
way to salvage the bishop
then we're going to go probably queen g4
just go after the spawn
there goes rook d8 we can take on d8
actually
that's simple but we can also just go
queen g4 and go after the spawn and
the fact remains his rook is
unsalvageable
knight h6 take this guy
then we're gonna take the rook and then
the night
yeah it's crushing okay
so he's a problem i don't know if he's
going to resign
speedrun with peace odds i thought about
that actually i thought about blundering
a piece
every game to start but i felt like that
would get repetitive because i would the
game would
keep having one type of arc i would go
for tricks
and eventually i would trick most people
below like 1600
but i feel like that would be a little
one-dimensional that's an interesting
idea though
so to recap
knight c6 right now d5
is tempting because it attacks the
knight but it closes down the center
and closing down the center situation
like this isn't always the best idea we
want to keep the center open that allows
us to play aggressively so this is
fine for white white is slightly better
here it's a different type of position
more positional type of advantage um
and eventually we'll get to the subject
of how to play in closed positions
that's i
broached that in the 5-minute speed run
um
okay so d takes c5 knight takes c5
now knight c3 knight f6 is the mistake
and now we go f4 this is all very simple
e5 knight f3 and now bishop b5
so in the event of d takes e5
um there's two good ways to play here
there is i would sort of say a very
concrete
approach that goes after immediate
material again who can find
this concrete approach
no i'll i'll pull that out pagadido
yes bishop c6 intermediate move point is
to take on e5 in the knight forking the
two pawns
the drawback of that is that you give up
a potentially very valuable bishop you
might be cashing in too soon
and black obviously should defend the f7
pawn
and me you know you only win one pawn
and this is a dubious
um quality instead i would advocate very
strongly for f takes e5
and you basically play now as if the
queens were on the board what would you
do well you'd develop the bishop you'd
castle along
and despite the absence of queens you
have a huge initiative
i mean you guys should all see the
knight g5s and rook f1
your pieces you're not only much better
developed you're so much more active
okay quarterman thinking with the t1 i
hope that makes sense that's why we
played bishop b5
now we castle yeah we'll we'll switch uh
turns like at some point i'll play
positionally with white and aggressively
with black
i haven't decided where that threshold
will be though so take stakes
um black should give give this check and
go knight g7
at least trying to develop but this
doesn't really help and we can pile on
here by playing knight g5 that's that's
why opening the f file is so dangerous
openings like the vienna revolve
precisely around something like this
where we open the up file for the rook
we castle
and we just pile onto this pawn in f7
okay
so queen e7 95 and essentially this is
already crushing boom boom
and yeah knight t4 is is nice but
you know this move knight c3 is very
simple it's absolutely devastating
okay so takes takes now e6 check that's
that's actually the best move
and had he played f takes well he
actually did that flutters the fork
had he played queen takes e6 what would
be white's best move this is a tricky
position
i feel like some of you are going to
fall for a certain trick because i
almost fell for it
now it appears it appears
that well 95 oh 95 is good and you can
play 95 knight f7
just fork this and win one of the rooks
that's fine but if you wanted to exploit
the discovered check
you would want to go bishop f6 and win
the rook you would not want to go
bishop takes g7 shot that is very
tempting
why is it wrong who can explain that to
me how is this not just crushing you win
another rook
great
well lpxd you need to listen to yourself
okay so that's uh you know my sort of
personal thing and
it would have be you know that's that's
that yeah so he moves the king and the
rook attacks the queens these details
these tactical details
they are hard to spot and when you solve
a lot of stuff you're in good form you
notice these things
right so that's why we'd want to go
bishop f6 but instead he took
a 95 check and the game is over any
questions about this game
any questions about this game
it looks like we're pretty clear okay
um let's do one last one i'll give you
guys an encore
give you guys an encore
how did i develop my tactics well it's
it's not a one-word answer you know
what if he takes for the queen and then
king e8 um
well then it's mate bishop f6 and queen
takes d
a checkmate all right last one
scanning for tactics the opponent might
have
well it's the same thing that you do for
scanning your own tactics
i need to replace my headphones they
died
yeah there's no secret guys there's no
secret book it's the only secret is
incredibly hard work over
many many years okay
um no it's all good um
i explained d5 d5 is not bad and i i but
i just talked about this
again d5 is perfectly legitimate i want
to emphasize this is not bad it might
even be the computer's top choice
um but it leads to a closed position and
closed positions can be very hard to
play it's
very hard to create attacking chances
when the center is really clogged up
like this
all right